you know we have a fantastic program
tonight some great people are on
excellent show we have
uh you know before you go sure i'm sorry
to monopolize the whole that's okay man
we're just killing time and if you've
got something
to go well i i just i feel like i should
introduce
somebody who's been here before she's in
the audience tonight
everybody it's my little sister stacy
yeah hi there
uh hi there stacey it's really great to
see you again
thanks lacone it's awesome to see you
again
you know that reminds me uh stacy wanted
me to invite you
over to our family's house for
thanksgiving um
you know she still has a big crush on
you oh
that's great
shut up randy
stacy come on it's cute i mean she has
been
you know the the idea of you coming over
she's been looking forward to it for
weeks she's even
been rehearsing you know like if you
were to come over and actually i have
some pictures uh
here she is she's getting ready to serve
you some thanksgiving pie
that she made see that's you on it
that's that's so
she made that pie and that outfit is
yeah that's so cute that's
great that's so sweet and she she made a
special float for the thanksgiving day
parade
[Applause]
yeah it's a lot of work that is really
that's amazing that kind of dedication
that's great and show them the doll
stacey
no way andy no no come on show him the
doll you brought it
okay fine i am i made a little conan
out of some native american squash
that's that's really cool
that's really neat and then and then i
took my own hair
and i dyed it with carrot juice and i
made your hair with it
that is really beautiful thank you she's
she's crazy about you
thanks a lot andy now conan thinks i'm
like the
sultan of dorkistan no
i don't think you're the sultan of
dorkistan stacy
i think you're a wonderful young lady
you're just saying that no i'm not i
mean it
and i'm very flattered that you did all
that thanksgiving stuff for me i think
that's very cool i'm touched by it
you really mean that
well sure i mean that and believe me i'd
i would be there on thursday if i
didn't already have other plans
no
no need to ah
[Laughter]
you got you got other plans well yeah
you know i
i promised my girlfriend's parents that
that i'd go to their house oh that's
nice
that's good girlfriend that's funny
they that's nice of them to uh invite
you over to their house
well stacy they asked me like months ago
i'd love to come to your
house too i i just wish i could be two
places at once
that's cute two places at once so let me
just get this straight um
the the only way we could spend
thanksgiving together would be if there
was a breakdown in the time
space continuum now stacy don't get
upset come on
you back off big brother
unless you want some uh some five
knuckle stuffing shoved into that
butterball head of yours
and you listen up conan all right your
words
are cruel and they feel like shrapnel
piercing my already broken heart
but deep within my heart lies an army
an elegant and fiercely brave
infantry of hate
[Applause]
and although this this army has
rejection
buzzing by its head like bullets
it will beat upon the drums of conquest
with your bones
stacy i am so sorry okay
i i didn't mean to upset you
i'm so sorry too conan i i guess my
my thanksgiving spirit morphed into a
vengeful
poltergeist
no i i can understand how that would
happen stacy
hey you know look maybe maybe we can get
together
next thanksgiving that would be really
nice
yeah maybe she can make another crappy
squash head doll
all right you know what it's judgment
day [ __ ]
we're going to take a break we'll be
right back